what the [ __ ] does this mean I think we
all think we're smarter than we are so
yeah I think I'm pretty smart I did
really well on my SATs and a CTS however
after I had kids my brain has just
slowly disintegrated into a puddle of
mush if it's history I got it if it's
logic I don't have it I'm not a good
test taker I am a terrible test taker I
had to take my SATs on time because I
got such a low score the first time
if Robin can say that he's smarter than
me that's just like that's gonna be the
end of my life I think she's gonna kick
my ass if zach were to like beat me by
like really really far I would sort of
be like a little bit devastated this is
a test of mental maturity and taking it
you will show how well you understand
certain types of relationships and what
you do when you face new problems
I don't know what I've all that is I'm
starting to sweat these numbers are
making me sweat this is a halt synonym
synonym cinnamon synonyms I'm gonna
score so high somebody's almost like is
it too obvious are they trying to trick
me I don't know five dollars for one
year at 6% good then when you start
doing percentages I'm just like by
interest Oh God
how many 1-inch cubes can be placed in a
box five inches long four inches wide
and three inches high five long four
wide three so five by four by 360 what
is the number if divided by four is
equal to 1/6 of 72 6 times 8 is 48 6 6
times 9 is 54 666 72 so that's 12
what's divided by 4 equals 12 12 + 4 40
you
you
I got a 40 million okay okay I got a 36
all right I think we're are we in the
same persona or not no I you're like a
couple of ahead of me just which ones
you have the hardest ones doing so
[ __ ] pictures oh really
yeah I was good with the pictures the
math [ __ ] me I got 58 haha I got 67 well
whoop-dee-do you can be a bad test taker
but be like the smartest person in the
room but you just have test anxiety like
it's it's whatever I always thought like
standardized testing and testing in
general placated to a certain type of
person and it doesn't really mean you
not intelligent doesn't mean your IQ is
not as as grand as that person they may
not be as intelligent when it comes to
logic or Street knowledge and I think
that I think we got that Street
knowledge both M Street knowledge
these are Greece or New York he's got a
straight alleys